[Musique]
sportifs ou culturel communaux ou
intercommunaux les événements qui
animent la vie cinquantinoise tout au
long de l'année cré du lien entre les
habitants certains tels que le parisbres
Paris l'Open de France les mondiaux de
cyclisme ou la rider Cup permettent
également de faire connaître 50 ans
eline au-delà des frontières de la Glot
et même à l'international mais du plus
petit au plus grand tous sont
d'importance pour le bien vivre ensemble
petit tour d'horizon exemple avec des
événements aussi festifs que
citoyens mon voisin est très brocquante
comme j'ai besoin de vider mon garage
chaque année et ben je fais la brquante
avec lui on plaisante entre nous les
l'ambiance est toujours sympathique
c'est très convivial on rencontre plein
de gens un côté bon enfant les les
objets ont une deuxième vie des livres
pour les enfants des jeux de société à
Montini le 7 juin en cours pour la fête
d'automne en septembre la brocande de
printemps à Mani ou encore comme ici la
brocand d'Alfred fin mai à voisin les
vigrenier sont toujours des moments
privilégiés sur laagloot l'occasion
d'échanger et de se rencontrer on a cet
événement qui nous permet de d'aller au
contact de l'habitant et de fédérer
également ses habitants c'est un moment
un repère culturel dans le temps on va
accueillir à peu près plusieurs milliers
de personnes ben c'est vraiment un
événement familial puisque les enfants
sont avec les parents et c'est pour nous
c'est important que ces moments de de
loisirs commun familiaux existent c'est
de faire sortir les gens à la rencontre
des
autres les événements musicaux aussi
sont toujours créateurs de liens social
et notamment les trempelins chansons ou
rock comme celui qui est organisé à
voisin salle de la tour en mars ou
encore le tremplin ro de Montini le même
mois the choice il y avait encore tout
récemment celui de laavrière intitulé
les envoles j'en pense que du bien parce
que je reviens tous les ans ça nous
permet aussi de venir assister et et
pouvoir nous donner notre avis et en
général on en vient ébloui et on a on a
découvert plein plein de choses
intéressantes bah ça permet vraiment à
ce qu' a un peu d'activités sur la ville
il y a des enfants des ados des adultes
jusqu'à des cheveux blancs on va dire
sur l'ambiance c'est vrai qu'on est dans
une soirée très
conviviale on fait appel à des
associations local pour tenir un petit
bar une buvette c'est un temps de
d'échange pour le pour les
gens événement musical fédérateur par
excellence la fête de la musique est
également bien représentée à
Saint-Quentin en Yveline Coral à la
ville du à encour ou encore trois scènes
avec pop rock et musique classique à la
cour de Coville à voisin ou
programmation variée à gui en cours il y
en a pour tous les coups on a constaté
qu'on avait un public vraiment très
familial sur la sur la fête de la
musique c'est un public extrêmement mixé
euh à l'image d'ailleurs de la
programmation qui est faite hein puisque
on retrouve aussi bien de la musique
classique que du jazz que du rock et
cetera et cetera et tout cela se mélange
[Musique]
parfaitement le lien social et le vivre
ensemble passe aussi par la vie de
quartier encouragé à 50 ans nieline par
son réseau de médiathèque très dynamique
et toujours partie prenante dans les
événements fédérateurs comme ici à
hlencour au quartier descmar où la
médiathèque c'est allié au prisme cinéet
et à la librairie pour animer le
quartier pour le plus grand plaisir des
habitants et des commerçants
régulièrement donc il y a des animations
qui sont mises qui sont mises sur pied
par exemple pour le la nuit blanche
alors là tout tout le monde est sur le
pied de guerre hein la médiathèque le
cinéma Le Prisme et nous-même donc là
bon bah on fait nocturne il se passe des
choses à l'extérieur le prisme souvent à
des danseurs à l'extérieur des balades
avec des des récits à suivre de lieu en
lieu sur la place ça passe par le
magasin puisque les compteurs viennent
au magasin et donc le public se déplace
ensuite ils repartent à la médiathèque
pour faire des jeux de société pour
faire d'autres rencontres ils ont envie
vraiment qu'il a une vie de quartier ils
ont envie de pouvoir se promener le soir
au cette Mar ou venir le samedi et qu'il
se passe quelque chose rencontrer des
gens d'ailleurs c'est rigolo parce que
souvent lors de ces manifestations en
fait il y a des gens qui se rencontte
qu' séit pas vu depuis un petit moment
et ça fait des groupes ils discutent
entre eux mais voilà ils se retrouvent
le sport également permet de réunir les
habitants à l'échelle d'un quartier ou à
une échelle beaucoup plus large comme le
définature qui attire des habitants de
toute la gllo avec son village nature et
son trophée des entreprises il en est de
même des différentes courses comme la
course de printemps à voisin en mars le
Trail des SEP hameau à manie en octobre
laagill en course en avril ou encore
parcourir Montini également en octobre
dans la prochaine édition sera
fédératrice à plus d'un titre alors l'
de 2015 change tout à fait par rapport
aux éditions précédentes et cette année
on va s'orienter vers un trail urbain
qui va faire 13 km et qui pour la
première fois va vraiment parcourir tout
Montini c'est fédérateur parce qu'on a
les huit quartiers qui participent ces h
quartiers qui souvent enfin pas souvent
mais des fois sont un peu coupé les uns
des autres on a la participation des
conseils de quartier qui s'implique pour
fournir des bénévoles on essaie aussi
d'impliquer les associations
sportives des activités et des moments
fait Atur qui se prolongeront au moment
des vacances scolaires avec les
différentes plages installées sur les
communes de Saint quanttin en yeline
comme à trappe à Montini ou encore à la
base de loisir avec Beach au soleil
juste avant Amani il y aura remet tétong
qui se déroulera du 6 au 13 juillet au
programme bal feu d'artifice et pas que
un ensemble d'animation d'atelierers
artistique d'animation sportive on y
trouve des soirées avec du cinéma plein
air du théâtre plein air des des
ateliers scientifiques on a aussi des
activités sportives avec des structures
assez sensationnelles c'est un moment
festif de partage donc
intergénérationnel intergénérationnel
également la grande finale du
championnat d'improvisation théâtrale
intercollège qui réunit chaque année des
jeunes de toute l'agglomération et leur
famille au fur et à mesure voilà on est
à peu près depuis 16 ans maintenant
qu'on le fait sur toutes les villes de
550 an c'est un événement en fait qui
permet
de de de faire rencontrer les jeunes
entre eux de croiser aussi l'existence
de deux établissements scolaires c'est
vrai que les villes de Saint-Quentin ne
sont pas
composé socialement de la même manière
l'idée c'est vraiment de de de de créer
un un vrai échange culturel on a les
familles qui viennent soutenir leurs
enfants on a les voisins qui viennent on
a beaucoup de camarades de classe qui
viennent on a les professeurs qui
viennent sur sur cet événement là c'est
comme si on était une grande famille Mo
ma famille c'est la première fois que
que je les appelle pour venir on vair
faire quelque chose dans dans tous les
autres trucs que j'ai fait je les ai
jamais dit de venir ou quoi que ce soit
et le J depuis le jour où je les ai je
les ai invité à venir me voir ben ils
ont aimé ils ont voulu revenir plus plus
souvent voilà pour notre dossier
consacré aux événements fédérateurs
c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui mais je
vous retrouve le mois prochain pour un
nouveau numéro consacré aux activité
d'été à Saint-Quentin en Yveline d'ici
là portez-vous
bien
[Musique]